Hi, I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about not walking
backwards. So, this actually came from
one of the patrons. Um, they showed me a
video of them doing geioaza and I was
saying, "Oh, I think you it looks pretty
good, but you you move backwards more
than I would like to see and he wanted
to be filled in a little more on what I
meant by that." So, I'm going to talk
about that. I think this is a really
complex problem. So when I was doing uh
Iikido as a student uh well as
exclusively a student I had a teacher
who did lots of geowaza lots and lots of
geoa and we had a very big mat and so I
developed what I later called big mat
iikido uh and it's a kind of iikido that
can be done when you got a big mat
because you can run backwards a long way
and when people aren't actually pursuing
you like they're pursuing you to do
techniques you can get away with it but
as I worked on a small mat so once I
started teaching my garage. It didn't
work anymore because I just didn't have
that kind of room. And because I didn't
have that kind of room and I had more
aggressive attackers because in the
garage we were just beating each other
up. Um I started to realize that like
walking backwards is actually horrible.
Horrible. And so I developed a way to
talk about it. So I'm going to share
that with you now. I'm going to get Josh
over here. We're going to go to work.
Josh. All right. So let's talk about not
moving backwards and what that means.
Um, so in Iikido's schools, I think a
lot of people move backwards. The school
I came from was really bad about this.
And that's not that the teacher wasn't
saying stop moving backwards. He was,
but I I don't think he put the the
amount of emphasis on it that I do. Um,
and I think most schools don't because
they don't understand how bad it truly
is to move backwards. So, first of all,
if I was going to go with Josh, this is
what I'm basically talking about.
Actually, I'll do it. So, let's say Josh
comes with me and I blend. Okay? And
then Josh starts coming to me again. I'm
like, "Oh, I'm not ready to blend, so
let me get set." Boom. And so I see
where I'm walking backwards right there.
Okay. And that's really common,
especially when you get multiple
attackers and like someone feels like
they're in a position that they're like,
"I don't really know how to deal with
this position right now. So I need to
give myself some room so I can compute
how to deal with it and then I'll
engage." Okay? It's really horrible and
it's diminishing returns. So, first of
all, if I'm going after Josh and Josh is
going backwards, Josh moves slower
backwards than I go forward, right?
Okay. If you're in doubt of that, see if
any track and field event anyone has
ever run a sprint backwards, right? Has
anyone ever tried that? Because if it's
a fast way to run, then maybe people
should be running that way. But they
don't, you know? And when I say that,
you probably laugh because it's stupid,
right? Like, you know that you can't run
backwards nearly as fast you can run
forward. Even in the NFL where there's a
guy who's several guys whose job is
specifically to run backwards, they
can't run backwards as fast as the the
guys who can run forward at their level
can run forward, right? So, you just
can't run backwards as fast you can run
forwards. So, if he's trying to buy
himself time, he's actually not. He's
just kind of more slow. I mean, you can
see he's buying time. He's more slowly
losing time, but it's still diminishing,
right? Never going to get okay. you are
not in a position to receive force when
you're headed backwards because the
problem with it is as he goes backwards
if I shove him he's already headed in
that direction. So his pinchant is to
continue moving in that direction just
faster. So if someone smashes into you,
you can't brace, you can't anything,
right? So you might be able to turn and
roll, which is why we learn to roll, but
it's that's not going to be that good
for you. Josh cannot see behind himself
as well as I can see in front of myself,
right? And this is another obvious one.
These things are so obvious that when
you say them, people go, "Well, duh."
But they don't really think about what
that means. So, if Josh is moving
backwards, he can't see what's back
there and I can see what's over there.
So, I, if I'm clever, will kind of push
him to where I want into a corner, into
my friend, off a cliff, whatever it is I
want. Right? So, it's just inferior to
move backwards. Okay. Now, I understand
you want to buy yourself time. So, in a
second, I'm going to tell you how you
buy yourself time. Another thing I want
you to understand is the position of
muhani, which is the position you
perpetuate if you go backwards is the
worst position you can have. Right? So
if I'm like this and I'm coming after
Josh, he's perpetuating muhan me. Even
when I turn, Josh will turn also, right?
To deal with this. So it's bad for him.
He's in a bad position. Where Josh wants
to be is this way. There's no way he's
gonna get this way by walking backwards.
So he's not positionally improving
himself either. So, not only is he
making distance badly because he can't
do it as fast, he can't do it as
efficiently, but he also is not
positionally improving himself either.
He's not getting behind me, which is
what he wants to do. So, the answer to
this is to go forward. Now, that might
seem like it's contrary to other things
I've said. But, let me point out two
models for iikido. One is the common
model used and one's the model I more
regularly use at my school. Both models
are applicable and there's times for
both models, but let me just point out
that there are two models. One model is
as the Iikido guy, Josh stands there and
when I come at Josh, he does technique,
right? So I come at Josh and he does
technique there and I fly through the
air, right? Okay, so that's one model
and that's the model most commonly used,
right? If you look at um teachers uh at
demonstrations showing GIA, that's
basically the model they use. They
pretty much stand still. They might move
a little bit, they pretty much stand
still, then the other guy comes to them
and then they they blend with them. If
you're training exclusively in this
model and you can't figure out what to
do next, of course you walk backwards
because your thought process is I have
to be ahead of them, right? So
understand that Josh is ahead of me
because I have to go to Josh to do
something. So Josh thinks I have to be
ahead of him in order to do the
technique. So if I don't know what to do
right now, I'm going to move to make
sure I stay ahead of him and then when I
figure it out, I'll stop and let him
catch up to me and then I'll do the
technique. Right? But you're losing time
in that, right? So, what you need to do
is flip the script. Now, let me show you
another model, right? Okay. So, if Josh
is the she, another model could be Josh
coming towards me, moving a direction,
and then hitting me, right? So, we'll
switch. I mean, it's confusing, but let
me let me switch. Right? So, I'm going
to be she. I'm going to be the person
doing the technique. So, if we were
doing iikido technique, like shonuchi,
right? I'm she. So, I'd be the person
doing shunuchi. Okay? So look, I'm going
here and there's a guy in my way. And I
go to the side because I don't want to
deal with this guy. And I attack him
here. Now we're in the Shomonucci
position from before. And the model is
she is moving. It's not UK that's
moving. Right? So do you see these two
models? It could be confusing, but think
about this for a second. Let's make Josh
she in both cases. Either in one case
she is standing still and UK is going to
she and then she does the technique. The
other situation is she is coming to UK
getting offline and doing the technique.
Right? Make sense? Two different models.
If we understand the second model, if we
understand that model, we understand
what to do in situations where we can't
process what to do because what you do
is very simple. You don't go straight at
them. You go forward at an angle. That's
what you do, right? So, think if I'm she
I'm in a room. I want to get out of the
room, right? Josh is going to rape me or
something terrible. I don't want that,
right? So, when I know he's going to do
that, I got to get out of the room. So,
what am I going to do? Well, I'm not
going to run at him and fight him
because I'm scared this guy's going to
do something bad to me, right? So, what
I do, I cut an angle and I try and get
past him. Now, what's Josh going to do
when I cut an angle? Well, he's going to
cut an angle towards me. So, what do I
do? I cut an angle. Can I cut a sharp
one this way? If he shoots too much this
way, then I cut an angle back this way.
Right? So that model tells you what to
do in the going backward situation. And
why it's good is because you start
dictating to them what to do and you're
still ahead. Now look, in my theory of
Iikido, I tell you aheadedness is the
number one. Now, one way to see ahead is
if Josh is she and he's just standing
there, I come to him. So Josh is ahead
of me because I've got a I'm being
dictated to Josh as to where to go.
Okay. The other way that can happen
though is Josh cuts an angle. The second
he cut an angle, do you see he's ahead
of me? Because I had to shift to deal
with Josh. So, he's still ahead of me.
And so, when you're walking backwards,
you're no longer ahead because I know
where you are. I just takes me the time
to get there, right? So, your
aheadedness is diminishing. You're
losing the aheadedness. And you're kind
of just putting off the inevitable. So,
you really don't want to move backwards
for all those reasons. You don't make as
much power that way. You can't see that
way. You're not getting positionally
advantageous. You're not as fast that
way. So, all those things are bad. So,
what do you do in a situation where you
can't figure out what to do? You go at
them at an angle, right? So, all I do is
I go, sh I can't figure out where to go
and I go here and I go, here's the empty
space and I walk towards the empty space
and that's how I get out of there.
Right? So, if you're in a situation
where you don't know what to do, you go
at them and you cut an angle. If they
make a wide angle, you cut the other
angle. And that's as simple as it goes.
And then you can strike them in that.
So, as I cut the angle, I hit him. Now,
I've dictated him what to do. You better
bring up your hands. I'll hit you in the
head. If I hit them in the head, that's
cool. That's good technique. If not,
I've got shomonuchi eekyo through roio
and all the other things that come from
that. Right? So, this is another way to
get your techniques coming off again
when you find yourself walking
backwards. Don't walk backwards. You
should always be trying to get to the
position where you're most advantageous.
If you were in a locked in room, that
would always be the center of the room
because then they can't lock you against
a wall. If you're in a room that's got
an exit, it's always moving towards the
exit, right? So, that's always what
you're working. If there's obstacles,
you're working. So, you put the obstacle
between you and them. So, if there was a
table right there and Josh was after me,
I'd run over to this side of the table.
So, the table is in between me and Josh,
right? So, that's always the way I'm
thinking when I'm moving. I don't want
to move backwards. Now, we will move
backwards sometimes because we get
caught and there's no way around it, but
ideally, no backwards movement. So, I
hope this sus some things out for you.
Uh, I'm Christopher Hines. Joshua Tehi.
My Solar McDaniel's behind that camera
right there, and we'll see you in the
next video.